tributes are pouring in for
groundbreaking director John Singleton
this was a big surprise to a lot of
people yesterday he died at the age of
51 following complications from a stroke
Singleton's movies are being remembered
for bringing the stories of black
americans into the center of hollywood
and popular culture at 24 years old he
became the youngest-ever and first black
nominee for Best Director at the Oscars
for his movie boys in the hood Lattimore
duty of our streaming network that CBS n
shows us the influential lawmakers
legacy filmmakers rather legacy glad
good morning to you good morning John
Singleton was a prolific director
screenwriter and producer his films
grappled with race prejudice and poverty
and paved the way for many of today's
black Hollywood icons either they don't
know don't show
I don't care about what's going on in
the hood John Singleton signature film
was his first 1991's boys in the hood
the low-budget gritty coming-of-age
story about gang violence and racism
took place in the very neighborhood he
grew up in the film school they always
say write what you know and what do I
know
I know South Central Los Angeles
starring Cuba Gooding jr. and rapper Ice
Cube the film earned singleton critical
acclaim for his powerful and poignant
portrayal of the black experience in Los
Angeles funny one for me thank you
two years later singleton cast pop star
Janet Jackson in her first movie role in
poetic justice alongside rapper Tupac
Shakur and actress Regina king during
his nearly 30-year career singleton was
praised for representing black life on
screen he directed films and TV series
ranging from a remake of shaft with
samuel l.jackson to shows like empire
and he inspired a generation of black
actors and filmmakers who are now paying
tribute Jordan Peele called him a brave
artist and a true inspiration Ava
Duvernay
wrote he was a giant among us kind
committed and in a statement Ice Cube
said Singleton's love for the black
experience was contagious I've been in
this business for over 26 years and I
haven't lost my soul and I feel like
really cool that I had my highs and my
lows and stuff and I'd like I'm happy
singleton has criticized major studios
for not letting african-americans direct
films depicting black culture he leaves
behind seven children in a statement his
family said he was a loving father who
believed in higher education black
culture old-school music and the power
of film noir Wow thank you think what a
pioneer that is a word nor I just saw
him an event in California recently and
he was very happy this was so confusing
because two days ago one of his
daughters said that her grandmother was
really miss speaking when she said he's
not doing so well she'd said her dad was
recovering alright so it was a surprise
yesterday to hear me say it pastor it
very sad news no
sad news